facial recognition is a quite extreme
surveillance capability it's a very
controversial surveillance tactic but
unfortunately in the UK it has been used
by police more and more often and we're
seeing now post covered suddenly a
really rapid growth in the use of the
tactics in fact this was used at the
coronation so tens of thousands of
people obviously were scanned they're
just collecting data they're not looking
for criminals or anything like that they
then have a watch list of people that
they're looking for and they always say
we're only looking for serious criminals
but what we actually find is that they
can include people who aren't suspected
of any offense in some cases they put
people on there who possibly have mental
health problems there have been
protesters put on these lists so you can
load tens of thousands of faces onto a
facial recognition watch list and then
take the camera out and see who walks
past it effectively means that you're a
walking ID card